[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and we're back for episode 45 of the 13
o'clock podcast yeah what's the name of
this one this one we're going in another
true crime direction because you know
how much I like to do true crime we're
talking about the Villisca ax murders
and some other things as well now this
was a reader request a reader yeah a
listener request okay actually I have
been wanting to do the Villisca ax
murder case but I also want to talk
about you know because Villisca is kind
of a pretty well-known unsolved like
creepy unsolved murder but what a lot of
people don't know is that maybe like
there are some researchers that think
that whoever committed the Villisca ax
murders was also responsible for a bunch
of other ones because there were a bunch
of other weird axe murders in the
Midwest like right around that time but
don't get as much for some reason don't
get as much publicity as Villisca did
even though a lot of them are really
similar so there are some researchers
that think that that all of them were
perpetrated by the same person like an
axe wielding serial killer every way
so it's an unsolved suit unsolved serial
killer case maybe it could be yeah
alright but okay so before we get into
that let's since this is a true crime
topic as I mentioned on the show before
my next book to come out is going to be
a true crime compilation and that's that
happened as it happens Villisca will be
in there and it's going to be called the
faceless villain it's eventually going
to be three volumes but the first volume
should be out before October that's what
I'm shooting for but yes this will be
vol 1 from covering from 1900 and 1960
and it's like the creepiest unsolved
murders from kind of all over the world
mostly in the West like Europe and these
days but yeah it's probably it's going
to be like a serial killer version of
unseen man can be pretty long have a lot
of cases in it yeah and it's going to be
a series yeah so people will like it
people like series and people like
nonfiction so if this isn't a serial
killer thing is probably bigger than
even paranormal so yeah it's not just
serial killers it's all it's unsolved on
hallmark is creepy unsolved murder right
there's big market for that
yeah and I don't want to go a true-crime
book for a long time I really like I
mean I like all the topics we do on here
but I think that your card ones are my
favorites yeah it doesn't mean that
we're stop internal we're going to go
we'll do that too
yeah yeah I'm just I'm taking a break
condition true crap because I don't want
to do them yeah it would be cool so but
if you're more into the paranormal
obviously my new book newest book the
unseen hand is still out there if you
want to get a copy and print ebook or
audiobook yeah and if you liked it
please leave a review I would really
appreciate it it's hot as hell in here
right now I'm not kind of sleepy our air
conditioning broken that the central is
the central window the central went out
and we're we're gonna have it replaced
but we haven't had a replace yet so yeah
yeah and we live in Central Florida so
it's it's terrible yeah it was insured
though that takes time to go through the
paperwork every 13-year old unit yeah
man those things well air conditioning
doesn't last long to Florida we have
backup units as window units we can't
run a window unit in here you'll never
whatever yeah it'll be too loud to be
too out okay so it's like 90 degrees in
here we're dying the new channel is
almost ready we could launch it now if
we wanted to yeah I'll probably be
putting it up and you know sometime this
week or next week it's going to be a
list channel and this is awesome yeah
yeah it looks it looks really I'm gonna
try like I have I have a bundle of
videos like a small bundle of videos I
could put up I have seven that are done
and then I have a few more written and
so I might just put those up and then
start putting up water excuse me start
putting up one or two a week you know
vents forth so yeah that should be
pretty soon I've been working very hard
on that I think that's about all the
show that's about it and then other than
a project Entertainment Network we
always have to give them a shout-out
yeah yeah podcasts go through the roof
yeah but I don't know this case too much
so I was going to ride along kind of
like the audience I know you want to
research this whole thing under her for
really but if I don't make any sense
just because I'm hot you can edit it out
oh he's so helpful yeah we run up long
he's so helpful yeah yeah okay so anyway
if you are you know a student of true
crime or if you're interested in creepy
unsolved murders
you have no doubt heard of the Villisca
ax murder case it's one of the most
famous unsolved mass murders in American
history and it happened in 1912 now to
this day the house where it happened is
still there in Villisca Iowa and it is a
tourist attraction if you're into that
kind of thing you can net you can go and
you can do the whole tour and I'll tell
you all about the murders and you know
if you're a ghost hunter you can go
there and see if you can talk to some of
the victims or something like that what
makes me so memorable these murders
here's the thing well I guess so it's
probably a lot of things one it just
kind of came out of the blue it was an
entire family it happened while they
slept there wasn't any reason really
right and they never caught the person
that did it or really had much of an
idea who could have done it right it was
probably why people were in the family
six family members and two girl little
girls that were visiting them okay and
their good idea one of them may have
been more families that were wiped out
one yeah first that's what's interesting
and probably what I'll do is I'll
probably talk about Villisca before the
break and then after the break I kind of
want to get into some of the other cases
because I didn't really know this
because I'd heard of Villisca but there
were actually a bunch from about 1911 to
about 1914 there were a bunch of other
like mass acts murders with a similar
kind of thing where like a whole family
was taken out and they never caught the
person that did it and they were kind of
far apart most when we're in the Midwest
a couple were in the Pacific Northwest
they're not sure if those are the same
person or not a lot of times the mo was
the same yeah and it seems kind of
strange that it's not better known that
it might have been a wandering serial
killer because even though the towns
were far apart most of the murders
happened like real close to a railroad
so somebody could have been just like
traveling around the Midwest by train
and just hacking people up and get back
on a train and run it up well right off
the top of my head this before central
heating and air yeah that means that
each one of these houses heated itself
with a fireplace so they're cutting
firewood most likely yeah which meant
that there's axes around yeah which
means that you can just walk around walk
up to a house find the axe that they
used to cut their firewood and kill them
with that axe well that's what happened
I noticed indeed so they find an axe
most of them they do find the abstract
of the line
in the Oxbow long day Scott and see
that's you see what a genius I am well
no that's been best intention before
well the reason that there were probably
so many axe murders around the Sun is
like you said it's disputed West because
it was a weapon of convenience pretty
much every family in the Midwest had one
it would have been out in the yard and
also in the Midwest really nobody locks
their doors I mean everyone kind of knew
each other the legions they lived in
small towns and stuff like that so don't
get this out you don't lock your doors
in Mississippi especially if you live it
yeah and I mean you know if you were so
inclined and if you were kind of into
like hey I'm going to wipe out a whole
family with an axe for no reason
whatsoever then I mean it would would
have been fairly easy to pull off back
then you know the fact that it was just
so it was so gruesome and there were
like weird little details and stuff like
that but basically okay so this was 1912
and it was the evening of June 9th now
we have the Moore family it was Josiah
and Sarah they were in their forties and
they have four children
that evening they were at they were real
up in the Presbyterian Church the local
church and you know stuff like that so
they were at a little program that night
with all their kids and after the
program is over is about 9:00 p.m. and
they walked the three blocks back to
their house now the little daughter when
their little daughter's had two little
friends named Lena and Ines Dillinger
and they were going to come over and
spend the night it was a Sunday night so
they also all eight of them go back to
the house they all have some milk and
cookies they all go to bed now sometime
between midnight and 5:00 a.m. somebody
and they think that this somebody might
have been waiting for them like out like
sitting out in their barn because when
they went out in the barn they found
like a depression and the hay like
someone had been sitting there and then
there was like a Knothole in the wall so
they were thinking that maybe somebody
was sitting out in the barn looking out
into the yard waiting for these people
to come home and waiting for them to go
to bed so sometime between midnight and
5:00 a.m. somebody picks up the axe from
outside walked into their house because
it wasn't lost now the two little girls
that were visiting were sleeping in a
bedroom downstairs there were two
bedrooms upstairs one of them had the
parents the other one the four was the
four children whoever this person was
took the ax walked past the bedroom with
the to visiting girl
in it walked upstairs walked into Josiah
and Sarah's bedroom took the ax and
whacked
Josiah with the flat side of it which
goes to show that they're kind of used
to using an axe because if you tried it
and I don't know if there are any axe
murderers better but if you try to hit
someone with an axe with the sharp side
it'll get stuck and then the other
person will wake up and be like what are
you doing and all the broken stuff so he
didn't like slice them or cleave them
with the axe he actually bashed them
with the other side of it actually
whoever did this they swung the axe so
severely that there were axe couches in
the ceiling above the bed so he did hit
it with a flat side he acts he hit him
with the back of the axe now some say
flat of the absence a blunt side of the
accent valley man so yes probably the
one that died wasn't it too soon well
yeah so basically so what he did he
walks into the parents bedroom smashes
the man smashes the one before they even
wake up okay nobody else in the house
wakes up either we get it crow silently
yeah then he goes next door to the
children's best bedroom bashes all four
of the children then he goes downstairs
and bashes those two little girls now
one of those little girls they think
might have woke up for a second
Brooke because she was scooted down
farther on the bed and her nightgown was
kind of hyped up they don't know if he
pulled it up or if she was trying to
wriggle away from the axe but you know
he got her anyway or she just did dinner
sleep or she might have just done that
in her sleep they're not really sure but
you know they said if anyone woke up it
was her but she probably only woke up
for a second now there were a lot of
kind of strange little details and
because this was 1912 you know some
sources report one thing some sources
report another thing now the family was
not found until the next morning and the
next morning their neighbor who I
believe her name was Mary Peckham or
something like that she looked out the
window and she's like me that's funny no
you know usually they're all at the farm
you know usually they're up early
they're out you know letting out the
chickens and feeding the horses and all
this other kind of stuff and she didn't
see anybody so she calls up
Josiah's brother I think it was and said
hey there's no but
you know you might want to go check it
out so he goes to the house he had a key
now the doors were locked which means
that the killer must have locked the
doors on his way out because the doors
as far as they know had not been locked
before so he had a key he went in there
a minute later he comes tear-assing out
of the house and he says call the
marshal it's like it's horrible and
Allroad Agathe
so the marshal comes a couple doctors
come like all these people come now
here's where it gets kind of shitty this
was 1912 it was Iowa everybody knew
everybody
the minute everybody in town found out
about this axe murder townspeople were
trooping through the house wanting to
check it out right you know they didn't
really have a concept of we need to
secure the crime scene evidently you
know what I mean so it's like they just
have people and apparently according to
some sources one person they don't know
it was one town's person took a piece of
Josiah Moore's skull well as a keepsake
yeah like you do well in 1912 there
wasn't forensic sciences you know not
really didn't matter if 20 people walked
through the dam how they would you could
give him a totally pristine crime scene
and they'd screw it up probably they
knew about think they had fingerprinting
though there was there was no
application for fingerprints he has no
database right and I doubt they could
probably prove anything that probably
wasn't even really believed in court at
that time and then again I say oh I've
got your fingerprint their problem they
do 1/100 are the same you know you could
probably get away with that yeah you
probably goes like that guy in
witchcraft right yeah maybe there were
there was no such thing as professional
police departments in them in 1912 in
the United States not really not by
today's standards the the best thing
would have been something along the
lines of like today they would be like
security guards ya sadati not even a
security guard might have better
training than a policeman of the time
yeah but anyway okay so despite the sort
of circus that the entire investigation
ones they did manage to find out a
couple of things and find a couple of
things they determined that whoever
swung the axe was probably left-handed
they determined that what the person did
the murderer you know went up and killed
the Moors killed the kids
the other kids and then after he did
that he went back up and made the rounds
again and just smashed the [ __ ] out of
everyone's head they were just
obliterated yeah and he went back and
did that I bet you guys one of them woke
up well no they were all dead at that
point he killed them with a couple blows
all of them and then went back I bet you
had [ __ ] son [ __ ] one of them made
it and started dude it could be had come
back to life basically yeah oh [ __ ] he
killed Ellen because she went alone and
smashed them all to make sure that you
would be amazed when I was researching
the ax man in New Orleans case which is
another kind of famous case we might go
show about that one day but when I was
researching that for my book you would
be amazed at like how many people
survive
yeah and axe to the head you think it
would be pretty much immediately fatal
but that is not the case now a lot of
the axe man of New Orleans victims lived
actually and it's just unfortunate that
they didn't see who hit them or they
have lost their memory or whatever but
yeah a lot of those people did survive
even though they got hit in the head
with an axe but anyway when happened
there at one of a wardrobe but yeah it
might have but they think that the
person went all around the house again
did the rounds again and just smash
their heads into nothing there was
nothing left they were unrecognizable
another interesting thing he had done
was that he had taken a lamp from the
house and he'd taken the chimney off and
put it under a chair and then he had
taken the little wick and he bent it in
half and they think this was because he
wanted the house to be a limited and
enough for him to see what he was doing
but not bright enough that you know that
they would wake up or that someone from
the outside would see him there were a
couple other weird things all of the
victims had their heads had been covered
like he smashed all their heads and then
Josiah and Sarah he actually pulled the
bedclothes up over their heads the
children he took pieces of clothing and
draped them over their heads
the same thing with the little girls
downstairs another weird thing he did
was that he went around the house
because he hung out in there for a while
evidently after he'd killed everybody
and he got like aprons and dresses and
things like that and he covered up all
the windows and all the mirrors so they
don't know if that was I mean I can see
covering up the windows but the mirrors
that seems a little like a weird
superstition type again maybe he felt
weird walking
outside of a darkened house dead bodies
and their knees and CNN involving his
own reflection now there used to be and
I think we mentioned this on our
superstition show that there was a
common superstition that if you looked
into a mirror where there were dead
people present you would see the ghost
of the dead person or whatever their
soul would be trapped in it or something
like that so maybe it wasn't
superstition they didn't be on guys
it may be yeah another strange thing
they found the axe was was still there
and it was Josie's axe that have been
picked up from outside now here was the
weirdest thing in one of the bedrooms
where the little where the to visiting
little girls were they found part of a
broken keychain which apparently did not
belong to the Moore family and then they
also found a 2-pound slab of bacon which
had been wrapped in a towel and was left
leaned against the wall this may seem
like kind of an odd detail although I
did see one source that said that it
could have been used as a quote-unquote
masturbatory aid I think it's not real
but I mean I could see that I can't
really think of any other reason why
they why they would leave a slab of
bacon in the bedroom he was going to
take it maybe but he left it there like
leaning on the wall like deliberately
leaning against the wall like he left it
there so I don't know what that was for
right it's probably also significant
that now they're not sure if either of
the two little girls was sexually
assaulted but the older one who was 12
the one who looked like she had woken up
and her nightgown was hiked up now some
sources say that her underpants were
found underneath the bed but none of the
sources say that they could determine if
she was sexually assaulted so I don't
know if she was or and if they just
didn't have any way of determining that
I mean I'm sure they did have a way of
determining that but I don't editor I
don't know if they just didn't want to
report it was 1912 I don't know so
they're not sure you know most sources I
said well she could have been but they
don't know it's not really clear you
know which if she had been then maybe
that kind of would kind of explain the
bacon there maybe he was jerking it into
the vacant autumn
they also found a bowl of bloody water
which presumably the killer had used to
clean his hands off okay so the first
thing obviously robbery not a motive
nothing was taken other than the house
keys which the murder
used to lock up the house after he left
like I said this is a [ __ ] small town
in Iowa everybody knows everybody who
the hell could have done that now the
first person that they suspected was a
man who lived locally and he was also an
Iowa state senator his name was Frank
Jones the reason they think that well
you know the reason they think that he
might have had a motive was because
Josiah Moore used to work for him he had
like a farm equipment company now Josiah
Moore used to work for me work for him
for like five years seven years
something like that
evidently the two had had a falling-out
Josiah had quit and he had set up his
own competing business and had taken
Frank's most valuable client who was
John Deere along with him it said that
in town the two men hated each other so
much
that one of them if they saw one another
on the street they would cross the road
to avoid each other there were also
rumors that Josiah had had an affair
with Frank Jones's daughter-in-law you
know although that was never really
proved but that was the rumor anyway so
some people in town said oh yeah those
two guys hated each other now Frank
Jones like I said he was a senator he
was kind of an old man like oldest she
was 57 in 1912 and they don't think that
he was actually the person that swung
the axe they think he might have hired
somebody
now the person they think he might have
hired was named William Blackie
Mansfield now the reason they think they
might have hired him was because he was
not a real savory character and actually
one of the cases I'm going to describe
in the second half which happened in
Blue Island Illinois was actually
Mansfield family and he did kill them he
was convicted of it but that was his own
family that's not usually a serial
killer thing whereas it's like oh and he
did it for a financial game but anyway
so they think that some people thought
that Frank Jones might have hired this
Blackie Mansfield person to kill the
Moors because of this grudge that was
between them allegedly you know like I
said there's not a huge amount of
evidence but some people did think that
and the fact to that Frank Jones was a
Methodist and the Moores were
Presbyterians
kind of caused this huge like religious
strife like in the town so it was kind
of like you know Presbyterians against
meth
and all this other kind of stuff so now
people who thought that maybe it was
something is somebody else
there was another suspect and his name
was George Lynn no Lynn George
Jacqueline Kelly now he was an English
immigrant George Lynn George Jacqueline
Kelly so just first name yeah yeah yeah
he was that he was an English immigrant
and he was a little preacher a
Presbyterian now he was a little bitty
guy only 5 foot 2 by 119 pounds all
right little bitty fella and he was kind
of a wandering preacher now he was in
Villisca the night of the murders he had
been at the same presbyterian little
get-together that the Moore family had
been at he was also a known sexual
deviant as they would have said back in
the day he was a peeper he had been
caught in Villisca two nights before
peeping into windows he had been known
to in other towns where he lived to run
ads wanting secretaries who would type
in the nude you know that type of thing
yeah so like I said he was a peeper
stuff like that whether it was an
exporter I don't know they said now he
was left-handed
like the murderer was but he was also
little to be like swinging axes around
now another thing that was kind of
damning about him was that he actually
left Villisca on the 5:00 a.m. train
right after the people were murdered and
he admitted that he said yeah I caught a
train at 5:00 a.m. from Villisca and one
summer and he admitted that he had been
on that train too like an elderly couple
who had been on the same train as him
they claimed that Kelly had told them
there was a murder in Villisca and they
claimed that he told them this at 5:15
a.m. which was two hours before the
bodies were discovered which if that was
the case would be very damning however
now Kelly was indicted years later it
was 1917 and in this it came to light
now he'd actually confessed but then
recanted like the next day he's like
yeah I totally did it me like not over
my nose now the elderly couple that said
that he had said that there was a murder
there they changed their story they
reverse their testimony
it was also kind of fishy that he
apparently sent some bloody clothes
anonymously to a dry cleaner in a
neighboring town like a few days after
the murder oh and also he came back to
Villisca like like a week after the
murders and he said that he was in
Scotland Yard and he wanted to tour the
murder house so they let him tour that
because they didn't really know how idea
that sounds like something a guy would
didn't want to want to revisit the crime
scene yeah maybe so even though when he
confessed and all this other stuff but
he recanted it the elderly people
recanted their story and then all the
other stuff was like kind of not clear
now he was indicted the first time it
was a hung jury that so they they
convened a second one and the second one
let him go so apparently there wasn't
enough evidence to convict him and you
know so that was him it does kind of
yeah you know but I don't know like he
seems like a pervert like a weird creepy
pervert and just like that but and he
wasn't from the town no I could see em
oh yeah
somebody just blows into town kills and
then takes off yeah yeah and like I said
it could be apparently there wasn't
enough evidence there to indict him and
the weird thing too is that even though
to me he seems like a fairly likely
suspect you know the fact that there
were so many of these other axe murders
which I'm going to get into after the
break and the fact that nobody thought
to maybe pin them on him like maybe he
was doing like check his movements like
to see if he was in the same town as
these people I don't know if anyone ever
did that or not you know maybe he had
alibis for the other one and like I said
maybe all of these ones all of these axe
murders that took place in the Midwest
at this time here weren't the same
person even though some of them kind of
really do sound like they heard I mean I
think yeah so read the halfway mark yeah
so okay so when we get back like yes
because I think I covered most of the
most of the details in the Villisca case
now when we get back I want to talk
about the serial killer theory and how
there are these kind of other crimes
going on at the same time that had some
kind of similarities and some of the
cases they're thrown in with it the
similarities are actually exaggerated so
they think they may be more part of the
series but some of them actually do
sound like it was probably the same
perpetrator so we're going to take a
right now and we'll be back in just a
few minutes every person story has
something to teach us however is view
life how obstacles are overcome how joy
is felt how fears are faced how love is
expressed the matters of faith podcast
explores individual stories of people's
lives and how faith plays a part it may
not be your story but it may help shape
yours the matters of faith podcast with
Jay Wilburn is on project entertainment
network subculture corsets in clothing
is our favorite store for unusual
clothing shoes and accessories they
offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 our cast dead sexy
podcast
I'm your host Armand Rose Amelia Fridays
exclusively on project Entertainment
Network where I interview authors
publishers editors artists filmmakers
narrators the lady from Walmart whoever
I feel like talking to that's every
Friday arm cast right here on project
entertainment network
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we're back talk about the
Villisca ax murders and the possibility
that there was maybe an axe murdering
serial killer wandering around the
Midwest in the early 20th century so the
the theory that the Villisca ax murders
were committed by a serial killer was
actually put forward in 1913 only a year
after the murders and this was the put
forward by a guy named Special Agent
Matthew McLaury and he was in these kind
of forerunner of the FBI back then now
he thought that whoever committed the
Villisca crimes had also committed about
six other crimes that had gone on around
the same time and now this was before
Villisca there were some after Villisca
- the first one in the series well the
first thing I have to say is that
according to McLaury his theory he
thought that all of these murders were
committed by a guy named Henry Lee Moore
now there are a lot of reasons to think
that maybe that wasn't him I'm not
saying that these weren't all committed
by a serial killers that I think they
probably were but I don't think Henry
Lee Moore - it was that - McLaury
thought it was so we're talk a little
bit about that the first crime in the
series actually happened in Colorado
Springs and this was in September of
nineteen eleven which you know that was
quite a while before because Villisca
was in June early June 1912 now in
Colorado Springs this was a family of
six similar kind of thing the only
person not killed was the father Arthur
Burnham because he had tuberculosis he
had actually moved his whole family to
Colorado Springs so he could stay at you
know one of those sanatoriums
for his illness and his family lived in
a little house in town now he was at
that sanatorium and his family was at
their house now a neighbor thought that
she hadn't heard like a friend of the
wife whose name was Alice she hadn't
heard from the wife in a while and she
got worried actually this was her sister
and her friends are so she went to check
on the family and then she found Alice
and the Burnham's two children hacked to
death with an axe
another weird thing now this is only
three people but then some people said
you know we haven't seen their neighbors
for a
either so they went into the neighbor's
house which was a Henry F Wayne and his
wife and they had a baby daughter so
they go into the Wayne house and those
people had all been axed - death - now
the burdens in the Wayne's were friends
the Burnham Arthur Burnham had actually
told told Henry Wayne hey come out here
there's a house for sale next door to me
so somebody had busted in and killed
both these families now Arthur Burnham
the father of the first family was still
alive because he'd been at the
sanatorium so obviously you know
suspicion immediately fell on him
however he had actually been working at
the sanatorium which was 12 miles away
from the house and he had an alibi
because his roommate he had slept there
and his roommate said you know his
coffin kept me up all night and stuff
like that and there was no way to get
from the sanatorium to his house without
walking it was 12 miles he had
tuberculosis very badly and could barely
breathe
so they said there's no way that he
could walk 12 miles much less swung an
axe and killed six people so he was
pretty much led off with that there were
a couple other suspects there was you
know like an Italian immigrant named
Tony donnatal and he was like supposedly
friends with the wife and stuff but that
kind of didn't go anywhere anyway so
okay so there was another six people
packed to death in Colorado Springs and
he thinks McLaury thinks that this was
the first in the serial killers you know
line of killings a couple weeks later on
September 30th 1911 there was another
one this is in Monmouth Illinois this
was the guy was William Dawson he was a
janitor of the First Presbyterian Church
which is interesting because also
another Presbyterian connection there
and he was actually supposed to come and
open up the church for Sunday services
he didn't show up so you know neighbors
went to check it out now so him his wife
and his teenage daughter were dead in
their home skulls crushed by a heavy
object house was not locked blinds were
all drawn nothing inside was touched
everybody was just dead nothing was
missing now this case was interesting
because it wasn't an axe police got
bloodhounds out there and stuff like
that they actually found a bloody right
so someone had beaten it beating them to
death with a pipe but it was otherwise
kind of the same
so like I said it wasn't necessarily oh
the guy was an axe murderer he was just
using whatever was around maybe because
like I said it was a weapon of
convenience a big deal was made of the
fact that when they search the property
they found a flashlight and it had the
words Colorado Springs scratched into it
which seems kind of weird because there
have been another murder at Colorado
Springs so that's kind of the first
thing that caused them to link those two
crimes you know besides the fact that
they were only a few days apart you know
some people were accused of this it was
like a Swedish immigrant black guy named
loving Mitchell stuff like that like I
said nothing really went anywhere with
that one either little one two weeks
later Elsworth Kansas October 15th 1911
now this one this was the showman family
and it was the same kind of thing it was
a little farming community in Kansas
same kind of thing neighbor got worried
hadn't heard from him called up called
the house no answer and went to the
house and the door was open and found
Williams showman his wife Pauline and
their three children all dead also
bludgeoned to death with an axe and the
axe had been taken from the neighbor's
yard this also happened on a Sunday
night just like the Villisca crimes had
they found the axe on the property had
been washed off but it still had a
little bit of blood over it now an
interesting thing about this which kind
of ties it to the Villisca crime was
that whoever did it had taken an article
of clothing and covered up the telephone
of all things and what I telephone
looking at yeah no idiot Mitty
now today everybody's upset their phones
are watching them yeah they're smart TVs
are watching them maybe there was a
conspiracy theory base and it's true
those things are watching you maybe not
maybe there was a conspiracy theory back
in those days that a phone could listen
to you could listen to him yeah yeah
that's what well maybe like I said if
this was the same person that did the
Villisca one that covered up the mirrors
and stuff like that I mean it doesn't
that seem like the same kind of thing
like it seems like a paranoid person to
do is watching me they're listening you
know they can see me yeah so we covered
up the telephone now significantly also
just like in Villisca they found a lamp
with the chimney taken off and put under
a chair and the wick
in half just like in Villisca kind of
weird so I'm kind of feeling like at
least this one was probably the same
person even though you know one with
Kansas one was I would they're not that
far apart and this ended anyway little
villages could have done Oh see that's
what that's what I'm saying
I don't know because to me I mean like I
said it was a long time ago it was nine
to twelve I wasn't there but from
everything I've read it really seems to
me that little Reverend Kelly was the
most likely suspect for Villisca just
cuz I mean he seemed like a weirdo and I
and what what's the chances of a weirdo
being in a little town like that on the
exact same day somebody killed yeah I
mean he's been there for a few days he'd
been at for a few days but you know cuz
like I said he was always left at 5:00
a.m. like on the morning of ascension
seemed very very sketchy to me how big
was that town you know I don't know I
can not huge it was just like a little
farming town and they said everybody
knew everybody so it could have been
that large right but ask you soon yeah
he was like they call it like a
wandering minister so he just went from
all right yeah and like I said he
sounded now they have like copies of
like newspaper ads he's from like
looking for girls right to come do
secretarial work for hammering with
bunny rabbit ears though a little perv
like that if he was the one that was
doing it you think they're doing a lot
more evidence for sexual misconduct with
a little kids and the women right that's
what that's the only thing that kind of
makes me think it's not because like I
said he seems like a like a sexual cuz
they caught him like peeping in Windows
and Brooke like that the guy who's doing
this he seems like more like a drifter
who just needs a place to stay and maybe
seem to go through you know what wants
to feel power maybe over a situation
yeah no one ever wipe these people out
and make that please mind for this eat
and I mean I'm gonna go through this
[ __ ] then we'll leave no one will know
it's me I know I'm the masked Avenger
that kind of crap yeah shadow with the
shadow knows yeah it might have been if
I'd invent some don't lie to me I don't
like that yeah but yeah so this crime
also this else was Kansas one in
investigation of this case another name
came up his name was Charles
Mars ik I think I'm saying that right
arm are Jaques and this was actually
related like tangentially related to one
of the victims mrs. showman Charles Mars
ik was mrs. Sherman sister
ex-husband and he had actually been in
and out of prison a few times for
stealing wheat for like threatening
people and stuff like that
so you know they thought maybe that he
could have had something to do with it
maybe and he was actually related to Cup
a couple of the other cases too or his
name was brought up in a couple other
cases too
so he's kind of another possibility
another thing and I think I forgot to
mention this in the Villisca thing and
this was another thing that happened in
a couple of these other cases in the
case of Colorado Springs it was actually
two neighboring houses that were that
were murdered in Villisca they think
that the person who killed the people at
Villisca had tried to get into someone
else's house earlier or later they're
not really sure they said about 2:00
a.m. the woman who worked the overnight
of the telephone operating office she
said that she heard like a door rattling
like someone was trying to get in and
then she like Randall the winner looked
out and she couldn't see anybody like
she saw somebody running off so and that
happened on a couple of other occasions
to where there were you know the same
night that a murder took place you know
somebody reported hey someone was
looking at my window or someone tried to
get in my house or no I found my screen
outside like somebody trying to break in
or something like that so they think
that maybe he was just picking people at
random and then he couldn't get in one
place so he'd run off to another place
now at this point some newspapers were
starting to maybe link these earlier
crimes because keep in mind you know
these crimes Colorado Springs Ellsworth
this was before Villisca so Villisca
hadn't happened yet now there was
another crime and this happened about
five or six days before Villisca this
was in Paola Kansas this uh this was a
young man
Rollins Hudson he was 21 and he had his
wife Anna and they had just moved to
Paola Kansas now they um you know the
wife had been [ __ ] around and stuff
like that he had been telling people
about his wife being unfaithful bla bla
bla you know they fawn all the time all
this other stuff so neighbors said oh we
haven't seen them in a while couple of
neighbors go over push up in the
unlocked door find the bodies this was
kind of similar to Villisca to where it
looked like somebody had pulled the
comforter up over the victims head
either it looked like it they'd done it
like before hitting them so maybe I
don't know if they were trying to like
muffle the sound or something like that
there were also some speculations made
that the victims might have been
chloroformed before they were killed and
just like in a couple of the previous
crimes a screen had been removed like
someone had crawled in the window
nothing was missing from the house so
not robbery
they also found a lamp just like it was
going to like a couple other ones where
the chimney had been removed and put
under a chair now significantly like I
said this is impale of Kansas this
happened five days before the Villisca
crime and just like I was talking about
before it seemed like whoever did this
crime and Paola that killed these two
people tried to get in someone else's
house earlier because another family and
Paola earlier that evening said that
they had been awakened by the sound of
someone knocking over a lamp down
Spanish and then they ran downstairs and
saw somebody running out of their house
so this seems like a person that's just
going in random places and just you know
killing people he finds there it doesn't
seem like there's any rhyme or reason
okay so then five days later was the
Villisca crime which of course was in
Iowa now here a few months later was
like six months later in December of
1912 and this was in Columbia Missouri
now this was the crime that kind of got
the whole theory about Henry Lee Moore
being a serial killer because this crime
Henry Lee Moore was actually convicted
of however they were his family members
it was a little bit before Christmas
Henry Lee Moore came home and his mother
and grandmother lives there and he said
I'm going to come have Christmas with
you guys and stuff now he claimed that
he came home that morning you know the
door was locked all the curtains were
drawn and stuff like that he went next
door asked the neighbor you know where
his mom and grandmother were and then he
broke into the house and then he came
running back out and said they're dead
in there when he was questioned his
story kind of fell apart and it turned
out that he had probably done it because
he had written letters to like
girlfriends and stuff like that that you
know I'm gonna get their house after
they're dead and all this other stuff
although he seemed to have like a much
grander concept of how much the property
would bring but he thought he was going
to be like wealthy all this other stuff
so he had a motive
getting them out of the way so you know
and he had like all these dumb stories
about because he had blood stains on his
clothes no I had a nosebleed and all
that stuff and I like yeah right he was
convicted of those two crimes but like I
said the guy in 1913 the FBI guy who
thought that all these crimes were
related thought oh well Henry Lee Moore
obviously is the one that did it all
these ones starting with Colorado
Springs and and Villisca but the thing
is Henry Lee Moore couldn't have
committed the Villisca crime because he
had work records that showed he was like
400 miles away at the time and usually
dudes that kill their families for
financial gain are that's not usually a
serial killer right you know while I can
see owed he's an axe murderer he's an
axe murderer that we're all axe
murderers you know what I mean it's like
you know that was kind of the only
related thing how many cases total do we
have now
those were six now there were a couple
other ones that actually weren't part of
the guy's original theory but some
people think they might have been
related although these two were actually
in the Pacific Northwest these ones were
this the first one was in Arden Wald
which is right outside of Portland
Oregon and that was June 8 1911 this was
for victims William Hill his wife Ruth
and their two children and they had all
been killed by an axe now they found
bloody fingerprints on the scene but
couldn't match them to anybody
significantly in this case the wife and
the five year old daughter had been
raped okay which they didn't really find
evidence of in the other case like I
said no let's go sounds like this might
be a different offender even though it
was an axe murderer and this one
actually there were some valuables
missing so not a lot of stuff but a few
things were missing so that might have
been a different person you know even
though it was an ax murderer whole
family other things really similar can
we group these into groups and other
things are there any that can really can
be excluded I'm not sure yes this one
was some things were taken and the woman
and the girl were sexually assaulted but
I don't think that you can discount it
completely because they're not sure if
that little girl in the Villisca case
was sexually assaulted
I bet you
she wasn't you know I'm not entirely
sure this one usually when an offender
does that he advertises the fact that he
did that yeah I think the body proposes
and position it in a certain way to let
everybody know that he did you know it
is when I'm when I look at that Villisca
murder and then the other one that you
mentioned it was it sounded exactly just
like you know cover up the telephone
this is somebody who sneaks in does that
doesn't really enjoy it too much and
then tries to cover up the fact that he
did it he didn't even want to see
himself in the in the scene of the crime
yeah it covers up the the mirror all
right and then he covers up the phone so
nobody can hear it any ever not the
victim he covers that covers up the
victim so he doesn't have to see it this
is somebody who's trying to deny the
fact of what he just did he's trying to
erase himself from the crime scene yeah
the motive is very different from a
sexual predator yeah that's me
it's almost kind of like somebody who's
doing it out of necessity which he may
believe that was necessary
yeah and hearing voices you know and it
was telling him to do it even though he
didn't want to that kind of stuff yeah
because obviously whoever did Villisca
and some of these other murders they had
to have been not right obviously because
there was no reason they didn't take
anything wrong you know they don't think
it was anybody that hated the people
particularly a stereo Killers really you
know actually if you really get down to
a serial killer is really nothing more
than a serial rapist he just he just
kills the victims yeah that way they
can't testify on and eventually he gets
into killing the victims that killing
the victims as part of the sex that's
not what you see here yeah that doesn't
doesn't look like the behavior of a
serial sex offender or serial rapist
right more like to me it looks more like
somebody who thinks that what he's doing
is necessary so probably some kind of
you know psychotic yeah I mean is
hearing voices yeah do the devil's
making him do it yeah it definitely does
something like that yeah now the only
other crime that kind of happened around
that time was in Renier Washington and
that was in July 1911 and this was also
two victims a man and his wife
Archie Coble and his wife and it was
south of Tacoma now this one a guy was
actually convicted even though the
evidence against him was kinda
so they don't really know if this one
had to do with Villisca maybe not now
there was another one in October like
action Halloween 1911 that's an this was
in Mount Pleasant Iowa and this person
didn't die and this actually happened in
broad daylight
this woman her husband had just left for
work he got to work and then her grown
son who also lived there heard her
yelling and the grown son rush rushed in
there and found her across the bed or
headed Ben Bastion now she lived she was
unconscious for a few days but she did
live but just like in the Axman of New
Orleans case if you both looked out up
she could not remember what the person
had looked like or anything like that so
they don't know if that was the same I
don't think it's the same way it might
be I think the guy we're looking for
targets families it does seem like her
getting a family because pretty much all
of Italy similar one route children and
a house tale he's being told to target
these families for some reason maybe
because they're evil or something's
telling them that they're evil yeah you
know maybe you know he's not he's saving
them from their sins type of deal you
don't know yeah be something wacky yeah
I don't think it's a sexual motive I
really wouldn't make him technically by
the FBI's criteria as a serial killers
you know more like a mass murderer yeah
yeah because it doesn't have that kind
of doesn't have a sexual motive writing
I don't think of a sexual yeah it might
not have been if it was sexual it would
have been really sadistic to and there
have been a lot of signs of that signs
of torture he would have at least
humiliated the dead bodies by putting
the arranging them a certain way so when
people came to find him it was kinda me
yeah or scary like he said trying to
hide the SEM yes because the thing about
the Villisca crime like the other one
does it yeah if there was definitely a
sense of shame and like he was trying
like he should have shame himself she
should come here he was trying not to be
seen he was trying not to see himself
what are doing it and live like that it
was almost like he was trying to go
secretly closer killers are into it you
know the mean the the the gore and the
butchery is part of the sexual
experience yeah they're not gonna hide
it yeah definitely I mean other than
other than the savagery of like bashing
these peoples heads in the pulp rut but
like you said he might have just
not to make sure they were dead or a
minister you make sure that they
wouldn't wake up suffering you know
you're look at you you have to look at
it from from a twisted point of view
yeah well I already hit them I'm Angela
kill and if I'm gonna kill him I'll make
sure everybody did I don't want to get
up you know I mean wounded and be
staggering around you know suffering
like it I'm gonna put them out how quick
yeah and then I'm the hide the fact that
this happened I want to see it I don't
anybody else see it the authorities can
see it but I don't want anybody else
that's happened deal yeah this is
somebody who's got shame oh and I don't
want to look at myself after this yeah
yeah oh that phone the telephones listen
to me I'm gonna cover that up yeah you
know I want them to hear that creeps me
out that and the bacon creeped me out
more than anything is that was the same
person
yeah I don't think this whole mess with
it and masturbating with the bacon they
would have known Chris the bacon would
have been awful slimy wait so I don't
believe that I think probably what he
had plan to do is to take the bacon with
him and he forgot it yeah my man cuz if
you know the bacon was probably crashing
boy it'd be good to eat and he's a guy
like hey don't want that to go to waste
yeah if he's a guy on the road than me
and I mean yeah sure I'd have been a
little bit hungry yeah you know planning
ahead so yeah addicts murder on whole
families wears you out and it an
appetite I'd like salted bacon it can it
can you know it can survive that
refrigeration for quite a while
depending on you know how hot it is that
but yeah a true you might have a carry
that around for a couple of days you
know yeah I had actually never thought
of the masturbatory thing until I read
it like in one source that somebody said
oh maybe that's what it was for Brad
know there's no one else could figure
out why it would know he was going to
eat it or walk out there yeah maybe he
did hit and all the excitement I didn't
really have refrigeration then you know
had ice boxes yeah he's probably saw
that in the ice box it he goes well
that's gonna go to waste now I'm gonna
take it with ya
they won't he forgot to take it or II
changed his mind not I want to take that
with me it's taking and removing
something from the crime scene
yeah maybe he thought it was cursed well
no no just that maybe he can be proven
Ellen that bacon you know that kind of
deal so you said I'm gonna take yeah
yeah maybe well better of it he thought
better Road but anyway so the last crime
and remember I mentioned William Blackie
Mansfield before that some people
thought that Frank Jones the Iowa
senator had hired Blackie Mansfield to
murder the Villisca the family in
Villisca now actually there was a crime
in
Blue Island Illinois which was July 6
1914 and that that was Blackie Manfield
but they were family members again you
know so they don't really it could be
but maybe not and like I said it's so
long ago I don't know if anyone's going
to ever solve it now but I definitely
think I mean from everything I've read I
definitely think at least some of those
crimes that look that McCleary pointed
out were probably the same person yeah I
don't think it was that preacher yeah I
mean he seemed like I said he seems like
a weirdo and he seemed kind of like a
fairly likely suspect but I don't know I
mean you think that if they really
thought oh it could be him that they
would have checked his movements for the
other hawk you and I don't know if
anybody ever did that it was him
those crimes would have looked a lot
more sexual yeah these crimes don't
because he did just seemed like a
perfect he was a perv yeah alright so
that was in him oh yeah maybe this is
some kind of a homeless wanderer man
jumping railroad tracks trumpet train
tracks walking around you know he's
hearing voices he's not real mentally
healthy he's hungry he's got to have
someplace to sleep he sees a family
there you know maybe he feels jealousy
about the family or something the voice
is telling that right that family out
you know God's gonna allow him to sleep
there tonight type of you it's gonna be
something like that yeah I bet it and
then he just wanders off to the next one
and eventually he gets killed for
something else so you don't ever know
what he is yeah he makes a wrong move or
he gets put in prison for yeah but could
put he gets put in prison or he goes to
a hobo camp and runs his mouth or does
the wrong thing and some hollows kill
him you know you don't know yeah
probably someone go go yeah there's a
lot of that been in there the 19-hundred
yeah a lot of ex-partner students like I
was really surprised when it's like I
said when I started researching this
book because I knew about Villisca but I
didn't know about all these all these
other ones that were likewise unsolved I
also have a feeling though that he was
moving at night I think he was walking
around at night nighttime is a different
thing back in nineteen well yeah there
were no Street like there weren't many
cars and actually 1912 yeah there were
some cars but it wouldn't not out there
wouldn't matter well yeah it's not like
an hour's look it's not like now where
you're walking down a country road at
night and there's cars going with
headlight
everywhere you know no it wasn't like
that yeah I think he just moved at night
probably slept in the woods during the
day you know maybe this semi nocturnal
something like that yeah just a wanderer
yeah 19:12 was damn near the Wild West
there was still a Wild West shift going
on at that time well yeah I mean that
was on count that was more than a
hundred years ago yeah I think about it
yeah it's all I was always hot here it
really is out of here yeah well now I
have to stay in here and finish editing
all this yeah are you I know it sucks
okay that'll do it for this episode if
you enjoyed this topic then be sure to
pick up my book the faceless villain
when it comes out because I talk about
Villisca in there and talk a little bit
about a couple of the other crimes - in
that section and I'm sure you will
probably enjoy it because you know true
crime I liked your garage electric arm
we all liked your crime and if you like
our show please subscribe to our YouTube
channel or you know go over and listen
to all some of the other podcasts - on
project Entertainment Network because
I'm sure they appreciate this a bunch of
other cool podcasts on there also go to
wwl comm 13 o'clock and by some of our
t-shirts because they're pretty red and
I guess that'll probably do it for
episode 45 bye
why do expertise only attack
when your parsley or you're taking back
[Music]